okay Chapter seven the house ain't got
stuff in here
I love chicken wings I like grain
chicken wings I like white chicken wings
there's guys like a rich
thickbox the thick bucks
I just burn it look at that
dust print of a gun
in the fireplace Bernays out of the same
box burn them
nice
I see that but let me just check out
them real quick but I can
yes I say that this cam is too simple
compared to rusty leg rush that goes
[ __ ] sorry Ross [ __ ] using no puzzles
game
yeah I check these toys out real quick
what's out here a hammer no take that
tango see everything's like glowing -
it's like breeze I never [ __ ] like
hide the [ __ ] and rusty like
this one's a time machine anything a
trashcan hammer
far out
anything need a laptop what is this
there's a hole missing
it doesn't feel too solid he says light
talk to me a light for
hmm
mmm no a tanning bulb
and I pop
[ __ ] what I put at an Ewald
anything in attend a live in here anyone
ate a tan and looking for a tanning bulb
and again there now
okay switch to this bulb
oh [ __ ] I got lucky
mr. Lambert where are you
shit's [ __ ] bright no I know going
back now I'm back
what the [ __ ] did he come back
um someone came back lucky is like
growing plants in here
vegetables Twix
[Music]
there's that bottle shells
another [ __ ] door right here open
this one now
here's two egg with shelves
hmm I think break down the door I apply
used to axe
yeah baby it's alright now just like you
like it
how do i light it oh I'll probably have
to use the fire here Twiggy
maybe if they go for the roots right
yeah the white let me just check the
wine real quick
you know at the burn the brush out of
the way and get the axe
and these acts of chopped down door you
know Sam
there's no water in this thing all right
it doesn't use water
yeah yeah take a rain collection system
[Music]
it doesn't spray water who's so [ __ ]
those are nothing in this game that they
make sense
Canton Road it was you know I love
chicken I love turkey I love Brussels
sprouts I'm just I'm just a good eater
yes yes unleash your anger
uh hello that off fish
you're still here
camp the wine bottle that missing thing
unlock the door yeah get here haze here
stop right there whoa whoa wait uh mr.
Lambert sir it's me Joe I don't know you
what are you doing in my house you you
send me here
remember I've done no such thing for an
intruder you're not very bright you know
that for all the commotion you caused
getting in here you might as well have
brought a bulldozer she said now you
have exactly five seconds to explain
what you're doing here or so help me God
I'm pulling this trigger and sending you
on your way five I was sent here for why
you three you told me to find you to
warn you about the end of the world -
you were old with white hair and you got
shot oh god please don't shoot me mr.
Lambert this this you gave me this it's
an inter something chrono it's a time
machine
good catch I gave you that yes
I've never seen anything like it but on
the back that's my family signet I made
this it's simply magnificent
I gave this to you why who are you
name's Jo sir I'm just a janitor at the
arcon building I found you in a room
with a big round door in the basement
lab this morning and tell gel you said
you'd come from 40 years in the future
to stop the end of the world
they said I I guess I was the only one
around so you gave me this and told me
to find you and tell you all this and
I've been there the future I mean a
bunch of times and you were right mr.
Lambert everyone's gone my god so it did
come to pass they really did it those
greedy goddamn bastards I told them this
would happen
wait I was dying how a chopper said
you've been shot I had to actually find
you at the morgue to get this address
shot by whom no wait don't say anything
else you've succeeded in finding me
which means anything you tell me from
this point on could alter the course of
action that brought you to my doorstep
unless I know the better so you've seen
the future what did you see
great porn it's like a bad dream sir
everyone's gone
buildings you're coming apart it's all
just quiet what happened mr. Lambert it
is doctor dr. Leavitt and considering
all the effort you just went through to
find me not to mention bearing witness
to the horrific outcome of the biggest
breakthrough in the history of science I
suppose I owe you some kind of
explanation oh yeah you do
hello mr. cat I was 24 when I got hired
by Archon or Athena as it was Athena was
one of the many weapons R&D companies
formed during the Second World War
unlike other R&D companies that had
retooled themselves to pursuit peacetime
activities after the war Athena had made
enough money to continue chasing the
next big thing in defense technologies
they were betting the farm on post-war
Soviet expansion raising the level of
government paranoia to create a
lucrative market for esoteric weapons
research I'd say they made the right bet
still a theoretical physicist at MIT my
thesis on the possibility of time travel
via dimensional membranes got published
shortly after I was hired in 1961 caches
at company heads were so impressed they
gave me a team and a budget development
exceeded even my own expectations
and after only six years we had the
first primitive version of the time
machine up and running there's also a
cheesehead
our first successful trials involves
sending simple objects into the future
with a timed return
but with our con running out of money
that was all the company bigwigs needed
to secure a big fat contract with the
Department of Defense apparently we had
sold them on the idea that the
technology could be used to go back in
time and strangle communism in its
cradle hmm the reality of course was
that it couldn't due to the laws of
causality you can't travel back in time
beyond the point where time travel was
invented and sooner or later we had to
explain that to our benefactors when
they started pushing for progress
reports Arkon management had to come
clean but instead chose to ease
government concerns by claiming the
technology could be used to bring back
advanced weapons from the future but
this too was a lie by
at this point we'd already had our first
of many human trials and we knew there
would be no weapons in fact our results
were as terrifying as they were baffling
time pilots returned frenzied and
confused raving about empty streets and
human remains at first we assumed the
city had suffered a Soviet attack in the
near future and had been evacuated as a
result but as we pushed on further the
terrible reality became clear time
pilots started returning fatally ill
dying within a day or two from painful
convulsions some never returned we lost
several pilots machine prototypes and
other equipment when the first
contamination erupted in the lab we were
completely unprepared losing three lab
technicians to what we later identified
as an incredibly aggressive airborne
virus
although we weren't equipped to handle
bio hazards of this magnitude management
insisted we contain and study it [ __ ]
up to keep our pilots and the virus
alive long enough to study we co-opted
experimental cryo technology from
another project Lazarus and established
a makeshift virus lab once again the
bigwigs managed to spin our setbacks
into a success story for the Department
of Defense now claiming that the virus
could be cultivated for use as a
biological weapon the team threatened to
resign but outrage was swiftly quenched
by promises of massive salary increases
and stock options I didn't take the
bribe I'd witnessed the lethal
efficiency of the virus firsthand I knew
there was only one way this was going to
end so I handed in my resignation and
set up shop out here for over a year
I've been working to recreate the
technology to bring me back in time and
prevent mankind's extinction from ever
happening
and now you're here the harbinger of
doom with my doorstep wearing a boiler
suit and who could have imagined that
Judgment Day would begin like any other
Monday in May in any case unfathomable
as it may be that you were able to bring
this information to me knowing is only
half the battle
preventing the outbreak will require
more than me why don't you just do it me
wait what yes I'm afraid I must rely on
you one more time you must go back to
Archon and prevent the outbreak
no no that's I mean I'm really honored
and everything but believe me you're the
last person in the world I want to
entrust with this and I mean that quite
literally but by this time tomorrow the
entire city will have succumbed to chaos
has he nerve you're here now and you're
all I've got
wait but what about you can't you fix
this doc don't you have a plan I can't
go myself because that would break the
law of causality the only reason you are
here to warn me now is because I was
there to send you and the only reason I
was there to send you is because I was
able to bring my work to fruition here
but we have no time to waste it's the
only way we told me you found me this
morning correct yes but that means I
failed to stop it and the outbreak has
already begun the time pilot for today's
trials must have brought the virus back
from the future which then somehow got
out of the containment chamber and
spread that pilot is patient zero I need
you to destroy the supercomputer system
controlling the time machine all the
research data is stored there too you
must destroy it before the time listen
they're gonna be angry at a partner
defense
I'm reconfiguring your device to send
you back one day earlier this should
allow you ample time to return to Archon
and get inside on the other Shore from
here about 500 yards down the road is a
rest stop you'll find a van there fueled
and ready to go oh I already have a ride
which won't be there yesterday you ninny
stop interrupting me I'm such an na one
last thing and I need you to listen
carefully because this is very very
important make sure you do not meet the
earlier version of you why what will
happen no one knows for sure it's one of
the conundrums not yet accounted for
there are theories of course none of
them Pleasant
now let's get you ready alright baby
- sick ride how did I get myself into
this I nearly got killed trying to reach
dr. Lambert thinking he had a plan and
it turns out it's me
I'm the plan at least I don't have to
walk back as fans not as cool as the
ambulance but it has its charm and it
sure was nice of him to pack me lunch uh
uh kit where she packed me a can opener
for the beans there and some gas for the
bomb oh I'm sure I'll think of something
I've got several hours of driving ahead
of me after all
it'll be on this morning before I get to
our con I just hope I have enough time
mm-hmm
yeah driver ahead pretty boy don't I pay
far